yeah on to the next game with some like
805 again not sure if you got this
opening already let's go for an Enzo
again and I try to out the ancient
damage variation quite a couple of times
which with them quite some success
actually seems that people don't really
know how to play against it anymore I
must say that um my knowledge is also
limited of course but somehow it seems
so difficult for black
okay he's gone forward a very closed set
up here rook e8 feels a bit strange to
me but I guess you one story and wants
to bring the night to g6 at some point
the early closing of the center on has
one disadvantage for black he is not
able to attack the pawn weaknesses so
quickly okay it's gon be six what I'd
like to do is to to gain more space on
the Kings side not sure this is a good
idea of it seems a decent I'd like to do
is to play even g4 and then half g 5s in
the point too Wow interesting maybe you
want on g4 he wants to take on h4 ok
this is an idea
maybe I really need some more time to
prepare this geez three maybe
not sure I might have Queen f6 then
which could be annoying but I also don't
want to play Bishop f2
and the difficult position do I have
some alternatives queen of six actually
it's a really annoying move because he
gets there four square
not actually the move I wanted to make
but I didn't see anything else
and i would expect Queen f6 to come in
order to go to f4 ever play g4y m.d
played this
so what now
complicated position I guess it should
be should be should be fine for black
now yeah of course you can do this but I
can just retreat and I think he needs to
go back in the next couple of moves
change it to and look at one also decent
moves on me so I didn't think this was a
huge problem
after all it's not easy to open to to
open the position also for black you
just got b5 as an idea at f5 and f55
wary unlikely with the pieces positioned
like that and also be five is not easy
to to play play either yeah I guess is
he's heading for for our forum f5 really
I'm not sure that that you can
accomplish that i also have quincy to
over 12 this this is very surprising i
can just play G for now what happens now
it's not even a technical issue it's
hard to understand what you will do
after King f2 now f5 or will you just
retreat then
now I'm ready for g5 of course he wants
to play f6 maybe but I don't mind that I
can I could put the night on f5 hmm yeah
it still got a really silly position for
the Queen now I just threaten bishop age
6 it's hard to hard to say what he what
he could do against this you know this
will be my next smooth yes just wins the
Queen it some time warning it's not not
so easy because it's a very close
position but I can do some improving
moves first at least I think they are
improving
now I try to get my bishop to h5 it
didn't do anything before so there
should be an improvement yeah I don't
mind if he takes these two pawns should
be decisive
yes sir you cannot take you down now the
queen is on it on the way to h4 it takes
now I take with the bone and Bishop f5
this should be winning I guess don't
have so much time to kick you later this
but it should be winning
and I'll just take an tweenage form
still not not easy but i hope this
breakthrough the help Queen have six now
in the cards check
check check check check check psyllium
check white forfeits on time oh my how
for the completely winning position of
course I just was was a little bit too
slow why did I spend those seconds some
are around here I guess there was still
ok timewise cause the position is
reasonable almost half of the game from
black yeah everything winds age seven
wins everything so this was a stupid
move I could also just play Queen at
five of seven it doesn't have a move at
all yeah but okay it happens was so such
low time okay next game